manifestation à toulon place de l'opéra
une centaine de personnes se sont
rassemblées cet après midi pour
contester les décisions gouvernementales
politique sanitaire jugé dictatorial ou
à la sécurité globale qualifiée de
liberticide ou encore une situation
difficile pour les intermittents du
spectacle de nombreux artistes étaient
justement sur place on demande aussi des
droits sociaux pour tous dire que nous
intermittent on a eu une année blanche
nous a permis de patienter et de pouvoir
être soutenu pendant cette année on
devait retravailler
on n'a pas pu retravailler de façon
égale tous ceux qui étaient dans le
spectacle vivant n'ont pratiquement pas
pu retravailler tout ce qui était plus
dans l'audiovisuel on peut un peu
retravaillé
donc ils n'ont rien il ne va plus
cotiser ils n'ont pas pu être pays ils
ont été soutenus par ron farha
effectivement l'unedic mais les caisses
sont vides qu'on est contre ces lois
liberticides
voilà les lois qui sépare qui stigmatise
les gens voient là et qui font pas
sociétés qui font pas commun voilà donc
on est contre s'ils viennent nous
entraver notre liberté
il ya plein de domaines où la liberté
les libertés se réduisent
voilà en fait la perçoit que le temps
passe en effet plus du tout confiance à
ceux qui nous gouvernent à ceux qui sont
censés nous soigner
elle a envie de le dire le pastorat
finale pour moi c'est une scène entre al
ahly le à liberté c'est un une façon
déguisée de l'objet les gens à vacciner
pour qu'ils puissent a priori
fonctionner comme d'habitude